Житлові будинки…
Садочки…
Школи…
Лікарні…
Театр, де ховалися мирні мешканці…
Харків, Чернігів, Тростянець, Ірпінь, Гостомель, Буча, Волноваха, Маріуполь -
це міста, де цивільна інфраструктура зазнала найбільших руйнувань.
Щодо Маріуполя, кажуть в ООН, є дані не лише щодо великої кількості загиблих мирних мешканців,
а й підтвердження масових поховань.
Установити, скільки ж мешканців було вбито в місті від початку російського вторгнення, не змогли досі.
Якщо подивитися на Маріуполь, кількість цивільних жертв значно вища.
І ми намагаємося встановити цю кількість.
Приміром, у нас з’являється дедалі більше інформації про масові захоронення, які там є.
Про одне масове захоронення ми змогли отримати супутникову інформацію.
І за нашими оцінками, у цій братській могилі знаходиться 200 тіл.
Таких могил може бути значно більше, додають в ООН.
Десятки, сотні тисяч мирних людей в українських містах перебувають без їжі, води, зв’язку, медичної допомоги.
Загалом, за даними ООН станом на 26 березня, від початку війни в Україні
загинув щонайменше 1081 цивільний мешканець.
Ще 1707 людей дістали поранення. Серед загиблих - 143 дитини.
Утім, ці оцінки - приблизні, реальну кількість жертв у таких містах, як Волноваха або Маріуполь, наразі встановити неможливо.
Блокадний Маріуполь увійде в історію відповідальності за воєнні злочини.
Президент Байден заявив, що на його думку, в Україні чиняться воєнні злочини - особисто я згоден.
Не можна забувати про ще один рівень відповідальності, який гарантуватиме,
що кожного, хто скоює воєнні злочини в Україні, буде притягнуто до відповідальності -
як командувачів на полі бою, які отримують незаконні накази, так і тих, хто сидить у Кремлі -
вони мають це усвідомлювати просто зараз.
У скоєнні воєнних злочинів в Україні Росію обвинуватив і Євросоюз -
у заяві за підсумками останнього саміту в Брюсселі ЄС зазначає,
що російські війська завдають ударів по цивільних цілях - школах і лікарнях.
А це суперечить міжнародному праву. Однак не лише це свідчить про злочинні діяння Росії.
Під час дебатів про злочини в Україні йдеться по суті про дві різні дискусії.
Перший аспект - воєнна агресія як злочин.
Порушення заборони на насильство як принцип, проголошений ООН.
А по-друге, йдеться про порушення правил ведення війни.
Вони діють незалежно від першого принципу.
Будь-яка війна - байдуже, наскільки виправданою вона є - всі учасники конфлікту мають дотримувати певних правил.
Їх, приміром, зафіксовано в Женевській конвенції.
Тобто існують певні принципи - приміром, застосування сили має бути співмірним.
І байдуже - йдеться про військові чи цивільні цілі.
Влада США зібрала докази для обвинувачення російських військових у скоєнні воєнних злочинів в Україні -
їхні оцінки базуються як на даних відкритих джерел, так і на інформації спецслужб.
Розслідування щодо воєнних злочинів Росії на території України розпочали
і в Міжнародному кримінальному суді в Гаазі, а також у Федеральній прокуратурі Німеччини.
Зібрані дані можуть стати підставою для порушення кримінальних справ щодо конкретних обвинувачених.
Воєнні злочини є, докази провини є - розповіді свідків, відеозйомки.
У багатьох випадках вони однозначні. Зокрема обстріли однозначно невійськових цілей - тобто цивільних осіб.
Це стосується артилерії, а також удари з повітря по однозначно цивільних цілях.
Свідчення свідків злочинів німецькі слідчі збирають на території ФРН -
опитують прибулих до країни українських біженців.
На адресу Росії лунає багато обвинувачень, як-от - удари по житлових будинках, школах, лікарнях і торгових центрах.
Якщо їх дійсно використовують із цивільною, а не військовою метою -
тоді так, це дійсно воєнний злочин, тому що атакувати цивільні цілі не можна.
І злочином були би спроби перегнати біженців на територію Росії проти їхньої волі,
замість того, щоби дати їм можливість вийти в тому напрямку, який вони самі обрали.
А це все речі, у яких обвинувачують Росію.
Утім, додають експерти, щоби підозрювані у воєнних злочинах понесли відповідальність за свої вчинки,
по-перше, має закінчитися війна.
А по-друге, має змінитися політична система в РФ.
Адже у нинішніх умовах про видачу Москвою обвинувачених міжнародним судам мови бути не може.